foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
she was still in the Democratic Party
I had no idea
I didn't see her as a Democrats did you
[ __ ] that Russian asset
good riddance Tulsi gamber are you
kidding me
Twitter's losing its mind this morning
because Tulsi camera can put declares
she's not a Democrat man no [ __ ]
Sherlock
come on
you [ __ ] kidding me of course she's
not a Democrat she hasn't been for a
long time
if she ever really was
foreign
but you all think it's news so let's
let's talk about it for a minute oh my
God
listen she is a Russian shrill she loves
Putin Putin loves her and I don't know
if there was ever like a handshake
agreement between Russia and Tulsi
gabbard or if it was just that they knew
they could manipulate her
and they could do it you know with their
with their little
Internet troll Farms they can manipulate
her into believing that she had some
kind of stake
with her popularity that the bot barns
would create
now some of the democratic party bought
her [ __ ]
for a long time nationally but her
[ __ ] nonsense for a long time as if
she was gonna be some kind of hero for
the for the Democratic party because she
was a woman
look we support women we are pro-woman
we definitely want women to have equal
rights and equality
that's what we want as a party as a
whole as the pro-democracy wing of this
country
and what comes along with that
is when you get in bed with the [ __ ]
enemy we treat you with the same equity
and equality as any other [ __ ]
traitor we don't give a [ __ ] what is in
your britches we don't care
your [ __ ] traitor you're a [ __ ]
traitor that's just how it is Tulsi so
good [ __ ] riddance good [ __ ]
riddance to you you [ __ ] I don't use
that word a lot but again when it
applies I there's nothing I can do I
can't do anything about it and it's just
the word that applies when you are
standing behind and going on Tucker
Carlson's Trader TV News Network White
Privilege tonight
denigrating people of color when you is
one
using using
you the label as a Democrat
to [ __ ] support Vladimir Putin's
murderous regime you can go straight the
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off all the way the whole
way
and I don't I don't think anyone this
morning in the Democratic party is like
oh man this is really this is really
going to hurt us
oh [ __ ] especially after the night that
Tim Ryan had did you see that [ __ ] holy
actual [ __ ] if you want to go see a dead
body if you want to see a dead body you
gotta go watch these clips and we're
we're definitely gonna we're definitely
gonna run through those clips today
of how the Democrats just won the United
States Senate
doubt me
listen Mitch McConnell has been running
around Washington
talking quietly about how they're going
to lose the Senate
and how Mitch McConnell knows this
is he saw last night's debate coming
he saw it coming now also Greg Abbott
wouldn't even show up to debate Beto
which would have been a good idea for JD
Vance JD Vance would have a damn better
time
of winning the senate race in Ohio if he
just wouldn't have [ __ ] showed up
last night
it was a [ __ ] shutout
listen Ohio is full it's a rush belt
right
Blue Collar people in Ohio real tough
Blue Collar people
and Tim Ryan
made JD Vance look like a little [ __ ]
last night
dressed him the [ __ ] down
bent him over and spanked his little ass
and that is the brand of democrat that's
coming back folks
and I'm not patting myself on the back
but I'm telling you this brand a
Democrat that you come here every day
and see this brand of liberalism that
you come here every day and see it's not
[ __ ] weak
liberalism is not [ __ ] weak and Tim
Ryan showed how to show it last night
that is not your Nancy Pelosi Democrat
that was on stage last night
it is a Democrat that is willing to
stand and [ __ ] fight fascism
with the truth
so all all liberals everywhere I don't
give a [ __ ] what spectrum you're on
whether you're a Bernie Bros socialist
or you're a God are you consider
yourself a moderate or an independent
wherever you fall if you're
pro-democracy Tim Ryan just gave you a
master class last night
on how to handle these [ __ ] Nazis
I mean you could just take just a few
just a few seconds of the clip of Tim
Ryan you could play that on Ohio TV
everywhere
and motherfucker's gonna win last night
Tim I'm not I'm gonna get way ahead of
the race here I'm telling you last night
Tim Ryan won that race
there is no [ __ ] way there is no
[ __ ] way that JD Vance recovers from
what happened last night on on
television no [ __ ] way
he absolutely took him out behind the
Woodshed and [ __ ] left welps on his
little ass
and rightfully rightfully so JD Vance is
a little [ __ ]
he was calling Donald Trump America's
Hitler
do you got it you follow me he was
calling Donald Trump America's Hitler
and then he got on his [ __ ] knees and
begged kissed the ring for support from
America's Hitler in his mind [ __ ] JD
Vance all the way the [ __ ] off almost as
much as Tulsi gabbard
and Tim Ryan gave you a perfect example
a perfect example that liberalism is not
[ __ ] weak you dummies
liberalism has the actual punch behind
it and the reason why is because you
gotta work at liberalism it ain't
[ __ ] easy
it ain't [ __ ] easy to get all these
people who are pro-democracy and one
goddamn room and get them to agree on
things
authoritarianism is the [ __ ] the weak
man's government
you just get one [ __ ] to tell
you what to do tell you what to think
what you can and can't do that's [ __ ]
easy
you just go you just go right now to
Ukraine you just go right now to Iran
and you ask those folks you asked them
how hard it is
to believe in democracy how hard it is
to believe in Liberty and how difficult
how how weak they are get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ]
liberalism is not weak folks democracy
is not weak folks it is the strength
it is the strength of Liberty
and last night Tim Ryan stood on stage
and proved that to the entirety of the
Democratic Party
and he ate he ain't no [ __ ] moderate
I mean yeah great he wants to sell
himself that way in Ohio
but as far as our standards today that
we see on [ __ ] Trader TV news
networks like [ __ ] Fox News
he's he's a goddamn socialist for that
matter
but he's for decency
honestly that that's what makes you some
kind of scary communist anymore is
you're just decent
because let's be honest folks the
Republican party is nothing but a bunch
of [ __ ] predators
they're after you they're after your
children they're after your children's
education
they're after your [ __ ] Health Care
they want to kill it all they're [ __ ]
predators
they can't stop thinking about what
they're gonna take away from you because
you don't you don't get it but they do I
mean
you got to be you got to be Herschel
Walker's girlfriend to get a [ __ ]
abortion up in this [ __ ]
they're predators
they're [ __ ] predators and I'm not
just I mean they're weirdos they're
[ __ ] weirdos they can't stop talking
about bathrooms and children's genitalia
so they got that problem and they got
the Matt gatz's and Jim Jordan's in
their party so they got that [ __ ]
predatory problem but they're also
predatory towards your [ __ ] rights
and they're not gonna let up
so you have to be [ __ ] you have to
get in their [ __ ] face
just like Tim Ryan did last night with
JD Vance did you watch this
oh you're gonna watch it today you can't
you're not gonna you're not gonna look
away from this these are some of the
best [ __ ] clips that we've had in
months folks
Tim Ryan
absolutely makes JD Vance
look like a little [ __ ] that he is
because that's what JD Vance is he's a
phony he's a fraud
and Tim Ryan did such a good job
of absolutely slicing and dicing him
last night
and exposing him for the fraud that he
is
it's maga maga is it's it's a fraud
they don't want to make America great
again they want to make America fascist
period
that's what the American first Nazi
party wants to do
and Tim Ryan gave you a master class on
how to handle these [ __ ] I'm not just
talking about politicians okay look if
all the candidates out there watch and
listen to Tim Ryan last night and watch
them undress JD Vance on stage
Bend him over his knee and leave welps
all up and down that motherfucker's ass
but I'm talking to you
when you're out there and you got your
fam your Uncle Earl he talking about
what I've seen on Facebook
well there's this early group of
memories on Facebook we know everything
we do our own research
you want to know how to handle it go
watch that [ __ ] debate
go watch the debate
everyone everyone thought that Trump was
going to be some kind of [ __ ] some
kind of [ __ ] Trophy winner in Ohio
and Tim Ryan
absolutely tied JD Vance to Trump 100
last night
and he won the Ohio Senate race last
night no question hands down it's over
JD Vance might as well abort his
campaign it's just too bad his campaign
ain't one of Herschel Walker's
girlfriends
speaking of other [ __ ] shitty
candidates Herschel Walker
that [ __ ] needs to abort his
campaign too I don't know if it costs
700 to abort a campaign but by God I'd
give him 700 bucks I'd send him a get
well card
did you see that Tom Cotton Tom Cotton
the senator from Arkansas
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] he's gonna go
stop for Herschel Walker
now make this make sense
Tom Cotton believes that all abortion
all of it every single [ __ ] bit of it
is murder
no exception it's all murder
so he's gonna go stump for a [ __ ]
murderer in Georgia
by his logic
and we're gonna you should make him
[ __ ] own that
just like Tim Ryan made JD Vance own all
his nonsense last night
we can't let up on these [ __ ]
even after this election this next
election folks it is going to be huge
I have this great feeling inside of me
now I don't want to say it too much
because I don't want you to get your
[ __ ] hopes up and not go do what
you're supposed to do which is engage in
your democracy and lean all the way the
[ __ ] into it just like Tim Ryan did last
night on JD Vance's ass
I want you to [ __ ] totally lean into
this democracy right now in this moment
and and today Texas Paul is going to be
on he's going to tell you you better get
your [ __ ] ass out and register in
Texas this is the last goddamn day
for you to lean into your democracy if
you haven't done it yet you need to do
it
but it's time
it's time we lean all the way into these
son of a [ __ ] make Tom Cotton make
him make him own that he's gonna go
campaign for a [ __ ] murderer down in
Georgia
make him own it
make Greg Abbott own that he couldn't
show up for a [ __ ] debate and really
honestly I don't blame him I don't
really blame Greg Abbott I mean [ __ ]
what's he gonna say what's he gonna do
he gonna get his ass spanked on stage
like [ __ ] JD Vance did last night why
would he do that
the last time Beto just absolutely
[ __ ] eviscerated him
they're terrified they're scared folks
so much so that they're on stage at the
Nazi rally out in [ __ ] Arizona and
Nevada saying we're just going to steal
the election just make these secretaries
the states in charge and we'll just
steal the election and we'll make Donald
Trump the king
that's how [ __ ] scared they are of
you
and they should be terrified of you
because you hold the power
and folks I'm telling you
phrase from Jade from from Tim Ryan to
JD Vance last night the phrase that he
used he said the exhausted majority
the exhausted majority
because I I really you know I love
yelling and screaming into this
microphone every single day but I wish
our democracy did not [ __ ] depend on
it
I love coming and talking to you people
every single day and showing you who the
[ __ ] these fascists are
exposing them
making sure you don't look away and you
know the [ __ ] Stakes
and I like to mock them I like to laugh
at them but I really wish they'd crawl
back underneath their [ __ ] rocks and
I wish our democracy didn't depend on it
but it does
and I know you're sick and tired
I know I know that liberals Democrats
moderates Independents parents
people who just want to go do their
[ __ ] job and not have to worry about
going broke because of a medical bill
they just want to make sure they got
decent [ __ ] wages
that they can retire at some point one
of these [ __ ] days and not have to
worry about going [ __ ] broke
they're exhausted with this trumpism
[ __ ]
they're exhausted with them Banning
books abandoned Book Fairs abandoned
math because of critical race Theory
not letting you love who you want to
love stripping your [ __ ] rights away
from you for medical procedures that are
life-saving that are that privacy
between you and your [ __ ]
doctor
foreign
people are tired of of them attacking
their wives their daughters their
mothers
they're sick and [ __ ] tired of trump
and trumpism they're [ __ ] sick of it
they were sick of it in 2020. so much so
that eight million more people came out
and voted against Trump
I don't believe 81 million people voted
for Biden
hell of a lot of those [ __ ] 81
million voted against Trump because
they're [ __ ] sick of it and I believe
we can do the same thing this midterm
because the thing is we can't just beat
them
we have to send a message like Tim Ryan
sent the message to JD Vance last night
we're not we're not going to [ __ ] put
up with this [ __ ]
we're not letting down we're not gonna
quit we know they're not going to relent
so we shouldn't and we should lean all
the [ __ ] way in and pile them under
mountains and mountains of votes
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
they want to play games with our
democracy
will you play stupid [ __ ] games and
you win stupid [ __ ] prizes
so send them packing
get your ass out there and check your
registration
get out there get three of your friends
your family members to check their
registration get them to get three
people to check their registration or
register if they're not already because
in some states today's the last
[ __ ] day
today's the last day that you got to
make sure and secure that you can make
sure to save this democracy not just for
you but for your your wife your sister
your mother your cousin
your daughter
your son
your brother Your Community member your
friends
your fellow parishioners
it's time now right [ __ ] now is the
time
to take the gift that Tim Ryan gave us
last night
and absolutely smack them in the face
with it
I'm not opposed to punching Nazis are
you
it's time
they will take away your way of life
they'll do it just doubt me
they even have they even have Russian
assets trying to run around pretend
being Democrats
for years running around pretend being
Democrats go on Tucker Carlson's White
Privilege tonight
Shilling for Putin
the murderous dictator
trying to convince us I'm serious
they're trying to convince us
pro-democracy people with Tulsi gabbard
inside the Democratic Party
that Putin good oh Putin good we love
Putin we want him to be king of the
world
him Donald Trump get married
they rule the planet
stupid [ __ ] look what happened
to Tulsi gabbard right in the
[ __ ] trash where she belongs
that [ __ ] traitor
and it's time we do the the same goddamn
thing to the rest of these moglodytes
like Tulsi gabbard
right now is time
to dunk those [ __ ] in the trash
folks we got Texas Paul today you know
it's Tuesday God damn you know it's
Tuesday we got Texas Paul today's Taco
Tuesday
can't let that go
I'm excited to have Texas Paul on today
I can't wait to ask him about his
opinion
of how uh Tim Ryan absolutely demolished
Davey Vance in Ohio last night but I
also want to talk to him about this
debate that Greg Abbott apparently was
absent on sounds like there was a debate
there he was absent on uh but he's got
some news for us there's some news uh
that has been buried a little bit
underneath the national news from Uvalde
there's been a lot of EX exiting in
Uvaldi from the school system there not
just the police department but also
um some of the superintendents and stuff
so he's going to give us some updates on
that we're going to ask him some
questions about a protest that was going
on down there at Uvalde that seems to be
making change I also want to show Texas
Paul I found a video this morning
um it's a BBC report but it's it's a
it's about parents at a San Antonio high
school and how Texas has absolutely
they're terrifying torturing parents
because they [ __ ] can't pluck their
heads out of their ass and realize
that the gun laws are the things the gun
or the lack thereof
the access to guns in Texas is
absolutely terrifying students and
parents
torturing them
as a matter of fact
so much so that they're it's causing
Mass events at high schools when there
is a suspected shooter
I want to show him this video and get
his take on that
but before we go to a break I want to
tell you folks everyone has been getting
this shirt on store.thetonymichaels.com
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ]
the Liberty shirts are going like
hotcakes
everyone loves the mugs as well I'm
actually considering doing a hoodie on
this since we're getting to Winter maybe
even a sweater because you guys love
this design and I appreciate that you
love this design again I would not be
here I would not be here talking to you
without having said this in a tick tock
video almost two years ago
I said this phrase the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty and it is the motto it is
the driver of this show
and boy do you guys like this shirt so
let us know in the comments and go go
visit
store.detonymichaels.com at
store.thetonymichaels.com and check out
all the merch over there we really
appreciate the support as always here at
the Tony Michaels podcast and it's kind
of fun you guys you guys get a little
something you get to support us we get
to keep going we have to keep yelling
and screaming into the microphone and
you guys get to wear short I actually
ordered one for myself so I could show
you on the show what it kind of looks
like so I I don't know when I'll get it
I'm hoping to get it soon but I
appreciate all the support over on the
merch store you can go to store.they
Tony michaels.com pick up your Liberty
shirt today don't forget we get the the
dark Brandon shirts over there as well
there's dank Brandon merch as well if
you're if you're if you're feeling dank
and go pick up the day
merch oh my God I can't even believe did
you see this uh what before we go to
Texas ball because yeah
did you see that that Fox News and Sean
Hannity thought that a voicemail of Joe
Biden calling Hunter Biden telling him
how much he loves him trying to get him
help because he's got a drug problem
they thought that would be a bad thing
oh my god oh they really are off the
mark aren't they well it's on brand for
Republicans these [ __ ] Predators
everyone stick around we got Texas ball
coming up right after the bait don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
these this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
what that means
Tuesday is Taco Tuesday
one of our favorite dishes here on the
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
also Texas call Tuesday
we don't [ __ ] around here maybe
Michael's
Texas ball how are you this morning
oh man I feel like hammered [ __ ] but I'm
right or not so let's get it done yeah
I'm telling you that's right well I'm
fired up this morning I'm I'm so happy
that Tulsi gabbard finally figured out
that we do not want her in the
Democratic party Gabe Sanchez you
probably feel the same way don't you
uh your your mic isn't working but you
know
yeah well it'll get there so Texas ball
as as Gabe tries to figure out which mic
he's using you know what you know what I
think happened you know anything
happened here he shot a what was that uh
yesterday and he's probably he's
probably switching his mic there we go
hey there yeah there we go sorry yeah
you know what was that all that jazz do
I need Tulsi adios tells me
if that's what I'm assuming that's what
you're talking about why well Tulsi
gabbard has never been a Democrat as far
as I'm concerned I mean she's also done
one like she was Pro lgbtq and then she
as she was right right against him when
she was done well I mean I mean when
Putin pays your paycheck and Putin is
against you know gay gay people then you
cannot you cannot be for the lgbtq
community I mean this is just not a
thing there there's actually an Alex
Jones clip um I don't know if we'll get
to it today but it shows you exactly
what Tulsi gabbard's doing and exactly
what they Republican party's doing we've
known for a long time with the NRA that
the Russian the Russian apparatus had
infiltrated the NRA which we know the
NRA boy if if Republicans aren't sucking
at the teeth of the NRA they're not
they're not doing it correctly and I
think Texas Paul that's a little bit
what you're going to talk about today
because really honestly in Texas it
feels like to me and people in Texas
they see Uvaldi
um as something that can happen in every
single School building in the state of
Texas and they know that fences and door
locks are not going to prevent this
people are even freaking out when
there's just just a little bit of hint
that there's a shooter at a school and
these parents are arriving at these
schools and of course you know they're
terrified for their for their children
and their family members and some of
them have been met with the police and
it's almost just a huge Riot
um just because because they're
terrified because Republicans are
torturing Texans because they just can't
get a handle on what the problem is with
guns and it's guns
well actually you know they they know
what the problem is they know what the
problem is and and I'll disagree with
you a little bit a little bit I love I
love my guns my cabinet back there is
full of them I I've got some of the best
weapons money can buy
I don't carry them around
I don't solve problems with them and
that's the [ __ ] problem in this state
is you've got these [ __ ] [ __ ]
Republican sons of [ __ ] running
around that cannot [ __ ] deal with
reality they cannot [ __ ] deal with
reality so they create these goddamn
narratives I need my guns in case I got
to fight the government you know the
government might be making me do [ __ ] I
don't want to do like read
you know these [ __ ] running
around talking [ __ ] left and right and
create these [ __ ] psycho [ __ ]
narratives that are just [ __ ] [ __ ]
biggest [ __ ] in the world they are
every [ __ ] one of them you see a guy
walking down the street with a [ __ ]
gun on a hip you're looking at a
gigantic [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what
you're looking at as a guy that cannot
[ __ ] deal with reality that is so
goddamn afraid that an immigrant is
going to come over and steal my job at
Walmart that he's [ __ ] walking around
with a goddamn gun on his hip because
you know what he's really afraid of that
he can't run his [ __ ] mouth without
selling somebody telling them shut your
[ __ ] mouth you [ __ ] idiot
that's what he's afraid of
that is the [ __ ] problem that's the
[ __ ] problem it's just [ __ ]
narrative these right-wingers [ __ ]
create around guns and then you got
Maria boutina in the [ __ ] NRA a
goddamn spy for the Russian government
we know it they've told us they met her
with [ __ ] flowers at the goddamn
airport celebrating her how bad she
[ __ ] fist [ __ ] the [ __ ] NRA
and then they gave her a [ __ ]
lifetime job in the Duma of the Russian
government
in our Hancock
God damn uh okay I think I think we're
gonna change it you caught me on a bad
day you caught me on a bad day I got
vertigo going on if I fall out of my
chair keep rolling I'll crawl back up in
I'm telling you here's what I'll tell
you here's what I tell you we need to
change we need to change Tuesday from
Texas Paul and taco Tuesday to fire
Tuesday holy oh wow I don't know what
was in that coffee but God damn
well man it just pisses me off dude it
pisses me off I own some of the best
weapons money can buy I will not lie to
you my hunting rifle is made by a
company called Seiko that some [ __ ] is
45 years old and the bolt is still so
[ __ ] tight it is hard to rack that
weapon because it was engineered it was
machined to Perfection when it was made
do I walk around with [ __ ] guns all
the time hell no I carry a gun when I go
hunting I carry a gun when I go out back
buy my pond my custom Pond is also my
shooting Pond by the way very cathartic
place I'm telling you very cathartic
place
why because it's up on a hill my target
is down on the ground so I'm shooting
into the [ __ ] ground so my bullets
aren't going to my [ __ ] neighbor's
property I why because I am my brother's
keeper because I give a [ __ ] about
people
you know I don't need a gun on my hip to
take care of my [ __ ] arguments you
come at me I'll [ __ ] tell you
I'll tell you you won't intimidate me
it's [ __ ] that's who [ __ ] carries
guns [ __ ] that's who carries God we
live in the one of the safest goddamn
countries in the world except for what
gun violence
you take the gun violence off the table
we're the safest [ __ ] country in the
world and where does gun violence occur
in these little [ __ ] neighborhoods
one little dot in a big [ __ ] City
let's talk about Chicago for a second
everybody won't you know we'll get out
of Texas talk about Chicago
oh Chicago's violent Chicago Chicago is
not [ __ ] violent Chicago's the size
of Houston San Antonio and Austin put
together
you take the [ __ ] crime statistics
out of Chicago they're the same as if
you combine Houston San Antonio and
Austin together
and where's the violence in Chicago it's
one [ __ ] neighborhood
that is 90 of the gun violence in
[ __ ] Chicago one neighborhood
the rest of Chicago's Dreamland but
these ignorant [ __ ] bastards around
here walk around they talk about Chicago
like my God you gotta wear a [ __ ]
bulletproof vest you got a cosplay man
you got to have my AR-15 and my
bulletproof Pest and all this [ __ ]
these [ __ ] [ __ ] man they make
me sick
they make me sick these cost Patriot
little bastards like this anyways I'm
sorry yeah like this [ __ ] right
here you know what what the hell do you
need this [ __ ] weapon to order your
Subway sandwich for huh you little
[ __ ] [ __ ] what do you need that for
in public other than to prove to the
entire [ __ ] world that you are a
chicken [ __ ] little bastard that can't
walk out of your [ __ ] house to order
a goddamn Subway sandwich without your
hog legs on you know [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] idiot
you know every gun range I ever go to
has the same [ __ ] rules let me tell
you about guns okay real people real
people that love guns follow rules you
go to a gun range in the state of Texas
anywhere in the state of Texas there's a
[ __ ] rule that everybody has to
follow or the range Master will drag
your ass off the [ __ ] range and you
know what it is
no loaded weapons unless you are on the
firing line
unless you are on the firing line your
weapon cannot be loaded
you break that rule you're [ __ ] gone
but yet this [ __ ] idiot is walking
around Subway [ __ ] sandwiches with
his goddamn hog legs loaded just in case
they ain't got his oat wheat bread
[ __ ]
I I mean I knew you're gonna bring the
fire today because Texas Paul always
brings the fire but I feel like we're
doing the show from the cussing pond at
this point I apologize I apologize
I mean you've got Blake Masters talking
to Madison cawthorne I think it was like
last month I think and he was saying an
armed Society is a polite Society like
this is the this is the mentality of the
Republican Party the only way to fix a
gun problem is to throw more guns at it
not like oh maybe we should try to
course correct the gun problem itself
to have some common sense oh no on guns
see here's here's the reason why they
really don't want uh like red flag laws
[ __ ] like that because it's them that
will be red flagged that's why they
don't want it because it's it's guys
like this [ __ ] that will be red
flagged and he he'll immediately with
guns taken away from him because
immediately threat that's the problem
here that we have that motherfucker's
mentally ill that's what that is that
[ __ ] is mentally [ __ ] ill
he's got something wrong with him
because as soon as as soon as you try to
present that as an argument the
Republican party will say um no you know
just like whatever two weeks ago they
had the bill that was presented for
mental health services in schools the
Republican Party immediately was like
yeah we're not gonna fund that thing
even though we try to use Mental Illness
as a scapegoat to it to explain or
Justify why gun violence is the way it
is right now again not looking at the
actual thing that's killing people which
is the guns but if you're going to bring
up mental illness and say that's the
actual problem not the guns then you
better double down and back up your
claim by actually funding services and
not stripping them I mean we saw that
the Trump Administration strip those
Services during his time as president
and now Republicans want to say oh well
the real problem guys is mental illness
we have to take care of that it's not
the guns we can't have the government
taking our guns this guy is the same
[ __ ] idiot that would say I need
these guns to stop the government as if
the government doesn't have tanks Jets
[ __ ] rocket launchers if they wanted
to take you out they could take you out
in a matter of seconds they could take
you out before you even knew they were
going to take you out they could take
you out in the middle of the night and
your neighbors would still be wondering
where you were
I want to point something out on this
picture here
okay I you can't trust a guy carrying a
bazooka in a sandwich shop but you
really cannot trust a guy with blue
jeans that's got velcro pockets on the
back and [ __ ] cargo Pockets that got
Velcro on the side this is a guy you
cannot trust forget the [ __ ] bazooka
and the guns just you don't even have to
go past the pants this guy's wearing to
realize he's he's probably you can't
tell me that this [ __ ] right
here doesn't use that bazooka because
it's not probably real it's probably a
prop so you can't tell me that he
doesn't use that thing to just store his
foot long Subs in it I mean that's what
it is
you know what he does you know what he
does and ladies forgive me for saying
this in the audience forgive me for
saying this but he shoves his pocket
[ __ ] in the end of that [ __ ] bazook
and just [ __ ] up the [ __ ] out of it
that's what he does with his [ __ ]
cosplay bazooka
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh I didn't I didn't no idea we were
gonna do Pocket [ __ ] content this
morning but I am happy that we are we
are all the way to this guy here
um [ __ ] the Bazooka that he has on
his back
um Texas Paul I I watched the video on
uh
Twitter this morning I believe or
someone had sent it to me I I can't
remember to be honest with you I was
trying to find something I'm so pissed
to Twitter right now I can't see
straight video what what'd they do what
Twitter called me a [ __ ] liar who
they tagged one of my videos and called
me a liar
what I've been pointing out for [ __ ]
ever that the state of Texas has been
throwing away [ __ ] ballots 28 000
ballots they threw out in the [ __ ]
primary you know what a big chunk of
ballots that is in a primary
we're not even talking the election 28
000 ballots they [ __ ] threw out I
made the comment Republicans are
cheating Republicans are taking for
using any excuse to throw out ballots so
dot your eyes and cross your t's and
make sure your early vote early voting
ballots and your mail-in ballots are
perfect they called me a [ __ ] liar
so I went at them I pulled up all the
[ __ ] articles and I started linking
them to Twitter I said here's my [ __ ]
receipts where's your [ __ ] receipts
call me a [ __ ] liar prove your [ __ ]
is this the new fact checker thing that
they got going on on Twitter because I
knew they were gonna have no [ __ ]
clue but that [ __ ] is gonna hear
from me
well I I I'm I uh I get your sentiment
there but I want to show you this video
again it's it's on Twitter
um I don't know how they feel about it
Twitter themselves
um about the uh validity of this if they
fact check it or not but this is a
report from the BBC this happened at a
school in Texas
um so I wanna I wanna get your take on
this it's it's almost two minutes long
but I want to watch the report here then
we can talk about it on the other side
let's watch this
I don't want to learn it
American parents are on edge at a time
of school shootings and lockdowns
in San Antonio Texas parents swarmed to
Jefferson High School after getting
notified of a suspected gun threat it
turned out to be false but for those who
were there it felt real
at one o'clock I got the text Mom I'm
scared we first heard the sirens wailing
from a distance and that's when like my
heart dropped I was like this is real
this is really real
tensions escalated between parents and
police
one broke a window with a knife and
multiple others were detained a lot of
people are saying that we overreacted on
the other parents overreacted we acted
out as parents concerned parents
inside the school anxiety was running
High among students as their shooting
drills became a reality an armed police
entered their classrooms searching for
threats
we put two bookcases in front of the
door so like no one would really come in
I was just like you know what I'm just
missing I look my I love yous to the
people that I I'm very close with
Jefferson High School is just 80 miles
from Uvalde that's where 19 young
children and two School teachers were
murdered in May the police have been
criticized for taking over an hour to
confront and kill the gunman Uvalde was
the prime example of the flaws in the
system my confidence in the police is
it's not there
it's not going to be the same especially
if you experience and witnessed
everything we should be safe in a school
we should be feeling safe within our
classroom
so there you have it um the
um the video of Jefferson High
um now this isn't just a problem near
Uvalde in Texas I'm assuming because of
how Republicans have not only
responded but really the non-response to
you voldi
um is what is terrifying parents
students and communities in Texas
because that's really the biggest story
here is that there hasn't been a
response from the Republicans in power
um I mean you would think that an event
like Uvaldi and the facts laying bare at
Uvaldi would make politicians who set
policy activate to set policy to protect
students
um to protect teachers administrative
officials police officers
their parents and the communities and
they absolutely have done the exact
opposite and it's because of of guys
like Greg Abbott and bazooka man who
like to Texas Paul said wants to uh have
fun with pocket [ __ ] in their guns
because that is the truth they are
derelict in their Duty here now Texas
Paul they're um and Uvaldi there has
been some news
um going on and of course it's been kind
of buried underneath some national news
here but there was a gentleman down
there protesting uh it seemed like 24
hours a day to get some [ __ ] done down
there
um and it seems like that has the ground
has been cracking there and something is
being done now the state officials are
not doing anything but they are doing
something in Uvalde itself tell us about
that
yeah Brett cross I mean I I don't
personally know Brett cross I don't know
what his politics is but I don't have to
I know that man is Texas
you saw those parents down at Jefferson
High School that's Texas
the police showed that they are
[ __ ]
[Music]
into that well we got to go home at
night [ __ ] well then get another [ __ ]
job because sometimes cops don't go home
that's the job
Brett cross sat outside the Unified
the uvale
Consolidated Independent School District
for 12 days let me tell you something
about Uvalde let me tell you something
about Texas okay the Great Plains run
all the way down through Dallas all the
way to just North of San Antonio
and then they stop and the Mexican in
the Mexican desert starts Uvalde is in
the middle of a [ __ ] desert it is dry
it is hot and Brett cross sat out there
for 12 days because
foreign
guys
it's okay
because this boy it was here Garcia
was one of the ones that were murdered
at Uvalde
and those [ __ ]
and Uvalde School District thought they
were gonna [ __ ] suck Greg Abbott's
[ __ ] and not do a goddamn thing that's
what they thought they were going to do
they were going to swing a little dick
and tell these parents how it is well I
got news for you this is Texas
[ __ ] this is Texas and Brett
cross stood out there for 12 days day
and night
eight Pistons [ __ ] outside the [ __ ]
Uvalde school district and said you will
suspend every one of these [ __ ]
officers you will suspend every member
of the Uvalde
police police force
the Uvalde school police force you will
suspend them and you will investigate
this so helping God I will not leave
until you do
and they did it
after 12 days of looking at at Brett
cross every day when they walked in the
door
they did it and the superintendent of
schools
the resign or well he didn't resign he
retired
but yeah he's getting it done and just
like the parents down at Jefferson High
School they're not waiting anymore
they know the police are going to be
[ __ ] chicken [ __ ]
you have a shooting at a school where my
grandkid is you bet your ass if I gotta
bust a [ __ ] window to get in there
I'm getting in there and getting kids
out I'm not waiting for these
[ __ ] that got to go home at the
end of the day
to make their decisions [ __ ] that noise
these are my babies you're talking about
no welcome to Texas that's how it works
you don't do the job I will
anyways try for being no no no uh now
everyone knows where the fire and the
heat came from the beginning of the
segment because um I think it's
important not to just to people in Texas
now in Texas they have a unique
situation where they got a governor who
is on the side of the gun and side of
the profit of the gun as opposed to the
safety of the the community
of Texas and the the other unique
situation that they have is in less than
a month they have the opportunity to go
have their voice heard
and today is the last day in Texas that
you have to register to make your voice
heard so my my bet is is that you're
going to tell us you better go get
registered but you don't take for
granted your registration that you think
you have in Texas you better go check
that son of a [ __ ] today if you haven't
already
because they're going to do everything
they can to make sure that they win and
I mean Republicans Greg Abbott did he
did he not show up at a debate last
night is that yeah do I get that right
yeah yeah
you know he he's he's worthless he's
[ __ ] worthless he is I mean he's a
wimp he's worthless he's useless he's I
mean a bill as simple as hey let's raise
the age to the to buy a assault rifle to
21.
pretty simple it's nothing big it
doesn't violate your rights doesn't it
a beer to buy a beer in the state of
Texas you must be 21 years old to buy a
goddamn can of beer but you at 18 can go
buy a [ __ ] assault rifle
and they and and because again they're
sucking that [ __ ] Russian spy NRA
[ __ ]
that dumped so much money in this state
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] Greg Abbott
would not even pass that law
that sorry piece of [ __ ]
you know we have a law that says you
have to have a class 3 license to have a
fully automatic weapon
they've they're fighting making bump
stocks [ __ ] illegal you know what a
bump stock is well it's a spring-loaded
stock it's a spring-loaded stock that
essentially turns your semiotic weapon
into a fully automatic weapon if you
just hold your [ __ ] finger still The
Recoil the weapon hits the spring kicks
back forward and fires again and again
again and again what was used in the Las
Vegas shooting essentially where yeah
where they shot where he shot 500
[ __ ] people
you know people forget this the numbers
on that
500 people from a hotel room what was he
on the 10th or 12th floor
blew out his window and shot I mean it
was well over a hundred yards and
because he had a bump stock on all his
weapons
you can hear listen to the audio on that
and tell me that's a semi-automatic
weapon tell me that you could fire that
many rounds you could squeeze your
friend your [ __ ] finger would lock up
from cramps from trying to fire that a
bump stock all you have to do is hold
your finger still that's it and the gun
will become a fully automatic weapon
your mouth you're modifying your [ __ ]
weapon to make it fully automatic that's
what you're doing
without a class 3 license without the
background checks without everything
else that goes with an FFL and and and
it's it's it's [ __ ] and Greg Greg
Abbott will not do a [ __ ] thing
useful in this state it doesn't matter
what it is it doesn't matter if it's
water it's energy
guns anything he does nothing useful in
this state
he wants to take your rights away he
wants to take your five rights away if
it doesn't have to do with guns I mean
he can't he can't even do the the basic
the basic level of of just being a human
which is even showing up to the funerals
of the Uvaldi victims can't even can't
even show himself can't even show
himself he can't I mean you you know we
we met we briefly mentioned about the
debate that love was last night he
didn't show up which again totally in
his wheelhouse of of doing but even when
they had the previous debate with Beto
he didn't want anyone else there because
he knew the people that were going to
show up were going to be the people that
were pissed that he didn't do anything
about the energy grid he didn't do
anything about the guns he didn't do
anything about Uvaldi he hasn't done
anything like the guy is completely
incompetent from doing his job because
he's paid so much by outside resources
but just the NRA or Russia or whoever
might be this guy doesn't care about
anyone in Texas does not give a flying
[ __ ] about anyone in Texas and you've
seen that through the whole time he's
been Governor anytime there's a problem
he points and blames to someone else or
points and distracts that oh it's
actually this thing and then when it
really comes down to the [ __ ] do your
job aspect of being a governor he's like
ah I would but
um you know what I just won't be there
and the lack of empathy the lack of just
doing the again the basic level of being
a human which is
showing empathy which we know the
Republican party in Fox News and Owen
and all these other [ __ ] don't have
it at all it's just not something that
they have or if they did have it they're
completely stripped away from it by
being indoctrinated by right-wing media
that says don't care about these people
only care about your first and second
amendment and when those things are
violated then you better [ __ ] get
real mad
but if there's anything else that's
about
they don't give a [ __ ] they don't give
one flying [ __ ] and Greg Abbott Ron
DeSantis anyone else these are all
symbols of that party and what they
stand for and what they stand for is
nothing but themselves
and it's it it's it I don't know I mean
yeah well I'll tell you that uh Texas
well I don't know if you know this but
um on Facebook we have this guy named
fake Gabe and um fake Gabe he usually
gets the wrath for me when he gets in
the chat and he starts [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] his Maga [ __ ] he's a he's a trump
copy machine is what he is now fake Gabe
I I know that you like to
get me riled up and make me make me
undress you like Tim Ryan did JD Vance
but I don't know that you want to [ __ ]
with Texas Paul today I just don't think
you want to but you but you think you
think it's a good idea to get in the
chat and to [ __ ] with Texas Paul today
so I wanna I wanna uh reassure you
because he says here Texas Paul he says
Paul is lying
bump bump sticks I guess bunks yeah bump
sticks do not work that way if they're
Sticks no bump sticks don't work that
way right but but I think he means bump
stocks and he's calling you a liar
dislike Twitter did and Gabe hey Gabe I
don't know if you've been here the whole
time
but there's been a lot of heat I don't
know that you want to really [ __ ] with
Texas ball this morning again it's
probably not a good idea to call him a
[ __ ] liar when it comes to mump
stocks when you know it's the truth when
I when I sit on the toilet and I take a
[ __ ] and get up and walk away with
what's left in that [ __ ] toilet knows
more about [ __ ] guns than [ __ ]
fake game does let me tell you something
a bump stock is a spring-loaded [ __ ]
stock that when you sit and hold your
weapon if you hold your finger [ __ ]
still The Recoil of the weapon pushes
back
against the spring and the spring pushes
it back forward and because you're
holding your [ __ ] finger still it
fires the weapon again so
it essentially turns your weapon into a
fully automatic weapon all you have to
do is hold your [ __ ] finger still you
lying cut piece of [ __ ]
big game I don't I don't I don't know if
that's the reaction that you were
looking for
um but you you certainly you certainly
got it here today because folks I just
want to reiterate that people are sick
and tired of people like fake game Maga
Republicans Trump copy machines just
absolute [ __ ] Liars shrills for Fox
News oan News Max and the rest of them
they're [ __ ] lies they're Republican
NRA Russian spy lies is what they are
and and and when you shrill for it you
really are because
guys Tim Ryan used a phrase last night
and I tweeted out just the phrase the
exhausted majority
because I truly believe in this country
people are sick and [ __ ] tired of the
trumpism and the lies and the [ __ ]
when people like fake game know they're
[ __ ] Ryan they know they're [ __ ]
lying they know they're bullshitting
they know they love to believe the lie
just because it makes them feel all warm
and cozy inside just like the guy with
the Bazooka who's a weak piece of [ __ ]
who has to have a bazooka strapped
around his shoulder to go order a
[ __ ] a six-inch Italian okay at
Subway it's the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
and the country is sick and tired of the
[ __ ] they're tired of the [ __ ] saying
you can't do anything it's not thing you
do we have to take away people's rights
it's just what we have to do because
because Christianity and God and Jesus
and [ __ ]
and you know who's tired of this [ __ ]
yeah do you know who's tired of this
[ __ ] Tim Ryan's side of this [ __ ]
because I guarantee you I watch that you
know I'm Gen X okay I grew up I remember
when Mortal Kombat was released as a
console video game okay I pumped a lot
of quarters in that [ __ ] and I
spent all night last night screaming
fatality I'm telling you Tim Ryan
beat the [ __ ] out of JD Vance I mean he
took him and just held him by the head
and said
and I mean over and over and over again
JD Vance was like this all night
I mean just bracing for what the [ __ ]
Tim Ryan was gonna say next I mean when
Tim Ryan said
Trump told you to your face you are here
to kiss my ass
and you walked out and said I love you
sir I love you I love you sir yeah yeah
I was like fraternity I mean
oh my God
there is nothing people follow strength
people follow strength and last night
they saw [ __ ] weakness against real
strength because Tim Ryan brought
receipts he didn't just come and talk
[ __ ] and say yeah he said let me tell
you why you're a [ __ ] you did this
and I've got video proof [ __ ] I
mean it was beautiful
it was beautiful it was it was The
Branding that the Democrats have been
looking for for a long time and and I
think I think more than anything uh Tim
Ryan proved last night that that that
brand of of liberalism if you want to
call it that uh him fetterman Beto uh
Val demmings she's really oh yeah she is
really slinging that the Democrats are
not [ __ ] around anymore and they are
the party that are going to stand up for
Americans they're going to stand up
against fascism for Americans for their
[ __ ] rights they're not going to put
up with this [ __ ] no more no more
Bourgeois Elite [ __ ] anymore they don't
give a [ __ ] it is time to take off the
gloves and do this fight for democracy
like we know how to do and I believe
that the exhausted majority
and I'm not just talking about people
who who
are of the democratic party I'm talking
about people who consider themselves
socialists Democratic socialists
liberals who consider themselves
moderates Democrats Independents [ __ ]
Republicans are sick and [ __ ] tired
of the Republican Party telling them
what they can believe what they can't
believe what religion they have to be
who they can [ __ ] love who their
[ __ ] neighbors who their [ __ ]
their brothers and their sisters and
their community members can [ __ ] love
what their wives sisters and their
mothers what medical procedures they can
and cannot have what privacy they can't
have with their [ __ ] doctors they're
[ __ ] tired of it and it doesn't mean
that they're giving up the exhausted
majority does not mean they're giving up
it means we're sick and tired of your
[ __ ] [ __ ] and we're sending you
[ __ ] packing it's enough of the stuff
enough of the [ __ ] enough of the
Marjorie Taylor green Lauren Boer Tulsi
gabbard Tucker Carlson Matt Getz Jim
Jordan
Ron DeSantis Greg Abbott Donald [ __ ]
Trump [ __ ] enough of it we're sick
of it and we're gonna send you packing
and today Texas ball tell us about it
because today is the last day in Texas
to check your [ __ ] registration now
is the time if you're in Texas to me if
you haven't already go check that [ __ ]
out and make sure if anyone who isn't
registered to vote that and they want to
hear their have their [ __ ] voice
heard they need to go today is the last
day
yeah today's not the last day we're in
the last few hours it is noon here in
the state of Texas a lot of these
offices close you cannot mail it in you
can't do it you got to take your ass
down to the courthouse and get [ __ ]
registered you've got to do it you've
got to be in line don't let them close
the doors on you do you have most of
these places will close down at four
o'clock they will they'll close at four
[ __ ] o'clock
I guarantee you on the last day they
will close down as early as humanly
possible if you let one Gap appear in
that line they will shut those [ __ ]
doors and lock them I guarantee you you
get your ass down and get registered
today I and I will tell you this lose
your [ __ ] job if your job will not
let you walk the [ __ ] off to go vote
lose your [ __ ] job because fascism
believe me you do not want to live under
fascism you don't believe me go take a
look at [ __ ] Hungary go take a look
at where they [ __ ] murdering people
in the goddamn streets you've got these
patrols that run around in [ __ ]
hungry and they pull people out of their
houses because they suspect them of
being gay and they [ __ ] murder them
you know I I I don't know what you don't
understand but this election is the most
important election you have ever had in
your lifetime because the Republicans
are telling you to your [ __ ] face
democracy is over if they win they're
going to hand it to the legislatures
which means democracy is over that means
whoever's in power now will always
declare themselves the winner
and that's it that's [ __ ] it the blue
States will be blue the red States will
be red and that is it and we will and
let me tell you what I tell I told a
pastor this to his face the other day
my daughters
my wife
my grandchildren are not going to lose
the rights that my mother and
grandmother fought to get them
and it isn't a question of whether it's
going to happen because we're going to
keep those rights we're going to keep
our democracy the question is how bad do
I make it for [ __ ] you before you get
the get this through your thick [ __ ]
skull
he said are you threatening to me I said
no I'm promising you you try to take my
democracy or you come in my kid and
[ __ ] it will be the worst and
last day of your [ __ ] life that's the
way it is we do not this is not an
argument
we are keeping our [ __ ] democracy we
are keeping our rights I am not handing
over my children my grandchildren's
rights because some [ __ ] [ __ ]
like Greg Abbott who knows [ __ ] all
about being a doctor has never worked in
an emergency room a day in his life
knows [ __ ] about a DNC or a DNA wants to
listen to some free [ __ ] Pastor who's
not even a real goddamn Christian he's a
[ __ ] corn artist
and they're going to take rights away
from Mike no you are not no you are not
[ __ ] the only debate we're
having is how bad do I have to make life
for [ __ ] you before you get it
through your head that's it that's the
debate we're having
antifa then antifa now and antifa
forever [ __ ] for [ __ ] ever
I am not putting up with fascism in
Texas Paul is not either Texas Paul and
Tuesdays are always fun but today holy
[ __ ] today was fiery I I I'm gonna
challenge you next week can we get can
we get more hotter than we are today I
don't know I don't know if we were or
not you know Texas ball joins us every
Tuesday and what you should do because
Texas Paul you do several shows on your
YouTube channel and you should go see
the heat over there
um everyone in the audience right now
who is listening to my voice go over to
Texas false YouTube Texas ball tell us
where they can find you to go go watch
the shows and tell us about the shows
that you do every week Wednesday
nights at uh at uh eight o'clock or nine
o'clock Central you will be getting our
pardon me eight o'clock Central you'll
be getting TNT me and Tennessee Brando
get together and do a show where we talk
about these issues Brando's talking
about the hijacking of Christianity uh
we're gonna have a good show tomorrow
and then every Sunday you can come have
coffee with me Sunday Sunday coffee with
Texas Paul I sit down at nine o'clock in
the morning because let's face it the
the the
media news shows that are out there are
crap
they're they're complete crap they don't
talk about real issues they don't talk
about what's really going on or really
affects your life so come have coffee
with me and we'll talk about it I
appreciate you guys and I apologize
don't want the heat you want the heat we
love the heat here on the Tony Michaels
podcast we do not want to let up we do
not want to relent we actually want to
make sure we spank Fascism and ass like
Tim Ryan did JD Vance last night and
that is that was beautiful that we
should go forward with because it is
enough of this [ __ ] because like you
said this is the most important election
of our democracy's lifetime the one that
is right in front of us less than four
weeks away right now and if you're in
Texas you got less than four hours in
some places to make sure you check your
registration it is vitally important
that you do that so that you have the
opportunity to vote out Fascism and vote
for better O'Rourke and all the way down
the ballot for Democrats and
pro-democracy candidates in Texas it is
super important because like we said
antifa then antifa now and antifa
forever [ __ ] and today's the deadline
in Florida too today's the deadline in
Florida well I don't care what state
you're in I don't care what county
you're in what district you're in I
don't give a [ __ ] go check your
registration today just pretend today is
the last day everywhere and go check
your registration but don't just do that
don't just stop there make sure your
friends your family check the
registration if they're not registered
get encourage them get [ __ ] give them
a ride buy a bus ticket pay for an Uber
to get them down to an election office
and register to vote because our
democracy's life depends on it this is
the most important election and Texas
Paul as soon as this one's over as soon
as this election's over and it's counted
and Democrats have piled mountains and
mountains and mountains on top of these
[ __ ] fascists the next election will
be the most important election Barn
democracy's lifetime we cannot relent we
cannot stop fighting they they are not
going to crawl back underneath their
rocks anytime soon they are out there
proud and they are they are ready they
are ready to take over our democracy and
kill it so we have we have to stand and
protect it and how you do that is to
lean into democracy Texas Paul as always
thanks for joining us my friend I can't
wait I can't wait for your show tomorrow
I'll be watching you in Tennessee
Paul on YouTube don't forget to watch
Wednesday TNT him and Texas Brando and
also Sunday go get some coffee with
Texas Paul Texas fall with the heat
today everyone stick around
what's that Texas ball you got something
Tony and Gabe best podcast available
right now Bar None you guys are killing
it love love you guys let me let me tell
you something when you're on it is the
hottest podcast on the [ __ ] internet
ever in the history of ever ever so
everyone again go follow Texas fall on
YouTube go watch Sunday coffee and
tomorrow TNT with him in Tennessee
Brando and everyone stick around don't
go anywhere I'm gonna show you these Tim
Ryan Clips right after this break good
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment [ __ ]
um
we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
I know he's fired up for democracy and
he's fired up Gabe because
it is a situation where democrats should
be fired up especially after last night
because if you're not fired up after
watching um Tim Ryan absolutely
demolishing JD Vance on stage at that
[ __ ] fraud that phony that is JD
Vance oh it's beautiful yes I mean we
really we really have come to the fork
in the road where Democrats the party
itself the people that are running for
office have to decide
do we go you know the normal route which
is we you know kind of play game be like
oh okay well you know we're better we
won't actually do that
or
do we say [ __ ] that man we're tired of
these things we're tired of our rights
getting taken away we're tired of our
voice being so you know a suppressed
we're tired of people being oppressed
we're tired of people being political
pawns at the end of the day you know the
Democratic party and those in it that
are running especially those who are
voting and have a voice you know as
these as the midterm elections come up
your voice matters now more than ever
and now we're beginning to see a
different side of their Democratic party
by just calling this [ __ ] out by saying
what's on our mind because it's almost
like they've been listening to the show
or something I'm just saying I don't
know but you know it for too long the
Democratic party and those who are
running have been kind of well we're
going to take it kind of easy won't say
anything to offend anyone and we'll do
this we won't do that now it's like [ __ ]
it man there's too much at risk there's
too much at stake that we can't we can't
not say something we have to say
something we have to speak up we have to
protest we have to show up you know I
mean you you've got people you've got
Merchant uh and uh and and fiori and
whatever else who all the other you got
cash Patel all these other people that
are showing up to these these Trump
rallies over the weekend that are
basically saying we're going to show up
in numbers we're gonna do this we're
gonna do that so it's like not only are
these people trying to use you know
intimidation factors but you also need
to show or you also need to see that
these people are are also showing up
these people are going to show up in
person and vote so you need to make sure
that you know we say it again you got to
have the buddy system but you got to
make sure that you bring your friend and
their friend brings their friend and
their friend brings their friend so you
guys are carpooling make it easy
coordinate schedule whatever you need to
do because at the end of the day if you
see these dumb [ __ ] who are out
there talking about President uh Biden
is is not actually who he says he is and
and impressive wearing a mask and all
kinds yeah and all this [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] where you're like what what world
what planet what timeline are we living
in right the hell is this [ __ ] when you
have to
stop and say what the [ __ ] is going on
and you realize what they're trying to
do and taking away these rights from us
then you say yeah you know what we need
to get people we need to get a [ __ ]
buddy system we need to show up because
if they're going to show up and these
dumb [ __ ] are going to like
other dumb [ __ ] like Marjorie
Taylor green Lauren bobert Herschel
Walker all these people then you have to
realize that you need to outnumber them
by showing up you know
the Republican party is going to show up
to intimidate they're going to bring
their militia they're going to call the
cops they're going to do whatever they
can to make sure that Democrats don't
vote that you don't show up that people
of color don't show up and let their
voice be heard that is what the
Republican party wants to do and so you
need to show up vote [ __ ] cast your
ballot and make sure that these people
these racist bigoted transphobic
homophobic
Russian assets
don't actually get
their position in power they don't
actually get to hold office because if
they do if these fascist people get to
show up and they get to hold office then
the rights that you hold so dear right
now won't be there by the next election
they won't be around for you to actually
speak up and say something
and that is what we're fighting for
never fails the Trump copy machine
in the chat he says what rats like the
one Texas Paul lost when he was lying I
don't know what you're talking about I
think you're talking about I think
you're talking about the right to a bump
stock or a bump stick honestly there's
literally like there's here you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna here's a link
I'm gonna put it in the [ __ ] chat
here and when you have a moment when
you've learned how to read fake game
when you when you've understood what cop
will actually know because how do you
understand if you can't comprehend
comprehend look
hire yourself a tutor right find someone
on Craigslist I don't give a [ __ ] go to
[ __ ] Duolingo to help understand what
English is I don't give a [ __ ] but you
need to get yourself go to a [ __ ]
neighbor and say do you know what this
means do you can you help me read this
because here's the thing
what he said is true what he called out
was true if you don't believe it then go
[ __ ] Google whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do go look what is a bump stock
you'll even see I put in the article
here from from The New York Times that
talks about the Las Vegas shooting that
he's talking about Gabe fake game
doesn't even understand that his orange
deity his Mussolini mango Jesus actually
federally banned bump stocks after that
shooting because there was almost no way
around it because it's just what it is
it's laid bare and really honestly fake
Gabe I hope you keep coming because
really the the comments I I mean I hope
you change your comments because you're
really it really is pathetic that you
said for these guys it almost makes me
think that you're you're like a sock
puppet account for Tulsi gabbard at this
point that's what it makes me think the
one thing I saw in these comments and I
have to go back and find it but fake
Gabe made a comment when when Texas Paul
was
was he you know very emotionally hit by
the shootings right talking about these
shootings began to tear up very [ __ ]
angry at the system that is broken in
Texas and the lack of leadership and
representation that bet uh that that uh
Governor Abbott has for Texans the lack
of empathy basic human understanding
just to care for another [ __ ] human
especially those who have been lost in
in a mass shooting
in the comments
fake Gabe decided to attack Texas Paul
for being uh unstable mentally unstable
and I just want to call that out because
I didn't want to interrupt Texas while
he was talking I also wanted to take it
a little bit easy and have mercy on fake
Gabe because I know if he [ __ ] saw
that [ __ ] dude lights out what I will
say is that when you come into this chat
and you say dumb [ __ ] that's fine right
you say dumb [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] rhetoric
stuff that isn't backed up you claim
local elections allow non-resident
aliens immigrants to vote and then yeah
the opposite exactly that it was [ __ ]
banned it was struck down such a [ __ ]
idiot but when you attack someone on a
personal level because I know that when
the facts when the facts are laid out
and you actually don't have them the
go-to thing to say is I'm gonna attack
this person personally on a personal
level
so when somebody
is
is hit emotionally with something that
is so close to home
especially in Texas
and you decide to say well this guy was
crying this guy was angry he's
emotionally and mentally unstable you
can go [ __ ] yourself fake Gabe because
you do not have the right to then call
out someone who is is trying to express
themselves
for the events that took place
locally within Texas something that he
cares about and you decide well the only
way I actually know how to strike this
guy down is by saying he's mentally
unstable
you can go [ __ ] yourself because here's
the thing at the end of the day you're
nothing but a [ __ ] cuck you stand
there typing behind your keyboard I've
invited you on the show before you won't
[ __ ] show up you've got this fake ass
beach photo at dusk [ __ ] photo over
here I don't know what the [ __ ] going
on there Google an image that that that
I can tell you for a fact that even when
I've invited you I've said hey man
[ __ ] come on yeah [ __ ] show up shut
up or show up is the end of the day you
won't [ __ ] do it all these trolls
will send you I will send you the link
right [ __ ] now for you to show your
[ __ ] face and say the things that
you've said the racist bigoted hateful
things that you've said on this show in
your comments [ __ ] behind the little
keyboard I [ __ ] dare you right now I
[ __ ] dare if you do it I'll pay you
50 bucks to show up with your [ __ ]
face on the show I [ __ ] dare you but
you won't do it no I won't because he he
doesn't he doesn't even understand
common common sense in government he has
no clue here's what he says he says San
Antonio has been under Democrat rule for
47 years what in the [ __ ] does that have
to do with what the [ __ ] is happening in
Texas why what the [ __ ] do you do you
think that the government in San Antonio
has any control over the gun laws in
Texas you are a dumb son of a [ __ ] you
are a stupid [ __ ] you just don't
understand that the simple the simple
mechanisms of government and why it's
important to have people who are
protecting communities not just in the
federal government not just in the state
government and not just in the local
government but all the governments that
are protecting communities because if
you don't if you have people who are not
protecting communities
in one of those governments [ __ ] happens
it [ __ ] fails and by the way by the
way same thing goes for Chicago they
always do this Gabe they do that you're
from Chicago
you had some of the most strict gun laws
yeah the the problem is they can just
drive to Missouri which isn't very far
and they can get as many guns they want
they drive to Indiana they get as many
guns as they want and they can drive
back the same reason why people in the
state of Illinois drive to Indiana to go
fight buy [ __ ] fireworks when I was a
kid that same day in Missouri same thing
in Missouri Missouri has Missouri has
almost no laws when it comes to
fireworks almost none especially if it's
a permanent firework stand if you go to
the Missouri Illinois border there are
[ __ ] firework stands all over the
highways out in the middle of nowhere
you're like why in the [ __ ] is there a
big ass building with a shitload of
fireworks in it because that's it's
right next to the [ __ ] Illinois
their fireworks and then go back
that's what happens the one thing I just
want to bring up is uh you know Texas
Paul's in the chat so I'm glad that he's
still here and I just want to point out
for [ __ ] fake game and anyone else
who wants to attack someone personally
for sharing how they feel about
something that is so close to home Texas
Paul shares right here he played
football at Jefferson High School so
this is not just a [ __ ] news clip it
is his community this is his people
so [ __ ] fake Gabe for trying to speak
out and represent those people from his
community especially those who are
victims
so I I we can move on but I just wanted
to call fake a for this because I saw it
in the chat earlier and I was not gonna
stand for that [ __ ] and I just
wanted to call attention to it because
I see this [ __ ] every day and fake Gabe
like I said you could say all the dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] you want but once you start
attacking someone personally and trying
to dismiss and say oh well this isn't
that and they're trying to belittle
someone's argument [ __ ] you especially
when it comes to something like this
right well and and again uh Texas Paul
is he just doesn't come here on Tuesday
Texas Paul is here almost every day he
may be lurking around in the chat but
he's here he's listening and he's
getting fired up and he's getting people
fired up there for democracy and that's
why that's why we love Texas ball here
um because of his fire for democracy and
his passion to make sure to save it
because again like we said earlier
antifa then antifa now and antifa
forever we are against Fascism and it
ain't no group there's no cookie sales
we don't get together on Thursdays we
just are [ __ ] we are anti-fascist and
we will not put up with the [ __ ] and we
will lean into it and and Gabe I got to
tell you I I really want to get to the
[ __ ] list right here and the reason why
is because I gotta show you these clips
from Tim Ryan so everyone that's hold
tight we're gonna go to the shitless
round of bringing around up all the
Tweety tweets and trendy Trends but I'm
going to show you these clips from Tim
Ryan uh hang on let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the [ __ ] list
wanna welcome back to the show you have
reached this shitless Roundup moving
around of all the Tweety tweets and
trendy Trends let's just get right into
it Gabe
now this is this is a clip but this is
Tim Ryan and it has the actual clips
that he's talking about as he's
eviscerating JD Vance and I hope the
volume is yeah I think we're good on the
volume listen this is this is fantastic
let's watch just a few weeks ago in in
Youngstown on the stage uh Donald Trump
said to JD Vance all you do is kiss my
ass to get my support
after Trump took JD Vance's dignity from
him on the stage in Youngstown JD Vance
got back up on stage and said start
shaking his hand take a picture saying
hey aren't we having a great time here
tonight
I don't know anybody I grew up with I
don't know anybody I went to high school
with that would allow somebody to take
their dignity like that and then get
back up on stage just uh you know fake
Davis always want me to play the whole
damn clip oh my God there's there's the
clip with the receipts
um and to show that Tim Ryan was
absolutely correct he quoted it exactly
correctly and he showed he showed Ohio
that hey this guy is a lion sack of [ __ ]
he's a fraud he's a phony and not only
that he's Trump's little [ __ ] yep he's
Trump's little [ __ ] and he'll do
anything for America's Hitler as JD
Vance he said it America's Hitler yeah
it's uh I mean
yeah I mean to call him you know with I
think it was a friend or a former
roommate I forget what the deal was but
JD van says oh yeah you know he's he's
America's Hitler right you know like
just he's like not as bad as Nixon I
think is what he said also in that
little message but you've got someone
who literally to your face says this guy
kissed my ass I didn't really know who
JD was before he didn't really like me
but then once he met me he loved me
right that's what Trump said at the
Youngstown Ohio rally right
and then you've got [ __ ] Tim Ryan on
there he's like look man
everything I'm saying right now is is is
true there are receipts and then of
course the internet in all of its Glory
I think it was acen or someone else just
was like all right let's cut these clips
together it was Asian that put that
together that's that's like the best
campaign to have like you like oh yeah
Tim Ryan could just take Aces work and
just start airing it on television in
Ohio and just at the end say I'm Tim
Ryan and I did that right yeah I I did
that I'm Tim Ryan and I I did not just I
approved this message I I did that [ __ ]
I mean that would be you know what they
should do they should pay for ads
four JD Vance they should pay for for
vote for JD Vance if you and then play
these things and then be like don't vote
for JD Advance this this ad was paid for
committee by Tim Ryan for JD Vance
um but yeah I mean this whole debate is
amazing oh it's great because here's
another example of him absolutely
burning down JD Vance's house now I'm
I'm confused because JD Vance I thought
it was JD Mandel remember this
all it wasn't just JD Mandel it was JP
that's right and then JD Mandel so
there's a couple
nicknames out there alternative people
yeah that's how pathetic it is he
doesn't know here's the thing if you
watch any of the debates that Trump does
nine times out of ten Trump does not
know who the person that he's talking
about right when Dr Oz was he was
stumping for Dr Oz He was like that guy
that guy he could not remember who he
was and then again you've got JD Vance
over here I'm surprised to even remember
who his name or what his name was other
than the fact he's like oh yeah that's
the guy that kissed my ass that didn't
like me but now he does like me okay
great because there was another guy in
the race Josh Mandel uh-huh so he got
the two cucks I mean both terrible
people but yeah right he made his own he
morphed into a JP JD Mandel combo right
well here is
here is Tim Ryan absolutely destroying
JD Vance over his trump-like fraudulent
charity like it it's it's embarrassing
it's that JD Vance would even attempt to
do this
but he did and Tim Ryan does not hold
back when calling him out on it this is
fantastic here please get injured
during the Insurrection when they tried
to overthrow the government beat him
upside the head with lead pipes spray
them with pepper spray the one video we
saw the cop got jammed into the the door
right JD Vance
raised money for the legal defense fund
of the insurrectionists this is the kind
of extremism JD that wait wait there are
so many moments here there's so many
moments here I'm getting them confused
this is the moment I I'm getting them
confused okay and I apologize but
there's just there's so many clips of
the Tim Ryan JD Vance debate where Tim
Ryan is absolutely setting him on fire
and JD Vance just stands there and takes
it he's like um right what else is he
gonna do right
um he's at and I would imagine that JD
Vance absolutely doesn't appear in a
room with Tim Ryan ever again like ever
again he will not appear in a room with
him just because of what happened last
night and JD Vance lost this race
because of last night but this is the
clip
where he's talking about how JD Vance
actually doesn't back the blue he's a
he's a treasonous piece of [ __ ] who
wants to pay for insurrectionist uh
legal fees let's watch that we wholly
reject you have video posts don't even
try to deny it we got we got yours we
got your Twitter posts and everything
else everybody's seen it he said help
these guys with their legal defense fund
now you can you imagine one guy saying
out of one side of his mouth he's
pro-cop and out of the other side of his
mouth he's raising money for the
insurrectionists who were beating up the
Capitol Police the one guy who tried to
raise money for got four years in prison
please get injured
ouch
ouch lady Vance doesn't even doesn't
even
he doesn't even try to refute he's like
[ __ ] uh well uh like you would think
that if you're gonna run as a republican
I mean a lot of the Republicans that we
know of that have run that are in office
or do run they typically oh wow and they
try to cause a lot of noise you can't
actually get a full clear clip of this
accusation
in fact being thrown at them but JD
Vance just like yep I'll let you say
exactly what you want to say I won't try
to interrupt you I won't try to really
do any sort of rebuttal I'll just let
you say what you got to say and uh
hopefully that doesn't come against me
right
and that's I want to see if I can find
the um
the clip here that I was thinking of
yeah about where he's is it the one
where he sets up the fake fund yeah for
the the non-profit and all oh yeah well
for for opioids yeah yeah that was a and
then he took the Pharma money yeah uh
well he it points uh a farmer let me see
if I can find there's again there's just
so many Clips I saw that I think I saw
that clip this morning I know which one
you're talking about the ash kisser one
is probably the most popular right now
because
it makes
um JD Vance look like such a [ __ ]
cuck
um and they are they're all Alpha Cuts
right that's that's what fake Gabe's
doing in the chat every [ __ ] day is
he's Alpha cucking for these [ __ ]
fascists
um and it's really pathetic but that's
just that's just what happens
when you have Republicans uh trying to
win elections that's the insurrectionist
oh I got it you got it okay send me over
that because I know the audience is
going to want to watch this one because
this just shows you what kind of a trump
fraud that JD Vance actually is yeah
um because that's the truth here that's
why uh JD Vance and Donald Trump get
along so well I mean right other than
being America's Hitler well but they
they Love Takes a fraud to Noah fraud
right but but they love all they love
their fraudulent Charities they love
them let's listen you know what I
haven't done I didn't start a fake
non-profit pretending like I was going
to help people with addiction okay I
can't I'm gonna rewind because that
just where the starting point where he
starts listen we have never we have
never in my in my lifetime
I haven't seen a debate like this where
a Democrat absent fatality finish him
um I have not seen Texas Paul says
fatality in the chat so he's hearkening
back to the Mortal Kombat get over here
finish him
um I am not watched a Democrat
take out
what seems to be the sharpest knives
that Democrats can find and absolutely
slice and dice a republican like Tim
Ryan did last night now again this is a
master class into how to handle these
fascist futs is because you can't relent
you can't be scared you just have to
start just like he does right here I
keep saying you know what I didn't do
yeah you know what I didn't do you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you know how
to do you know how I'm not a terrible
human being I'm not a trash human right
oh you want to see the bar of decency
I'll show it to you because he doesn't
reach it watch this this is hilarious
you know what I haven't done I didn't
start a fake non-profit pretending like
I was going to help people with
addiction like JD Vance did literally
started a non-profit and didn't spend
one nickel on anybody in fact he brought
in somebody from Purdue Pharma to be the
spokesperson
for the non-profit the same drug company
big Pharma the big drug company that had
all the pill Mills going got everybody
addicted one million people died JD one
million people died and you started a
non-profit to try to take advantage of
people in Ohio and you know what all you
did with it was launch your political
career his campaign manager worked for
that non-profit he ran a poll to check
his own standing from that non-profit
I'm not going to take a back seat to you
or anybody else on fentanyl drugs or
immigration or anything else somebody
that
listen anytime anything well no you wait
till I'm [ __ ] done you you shut your
[ __ ] mouth and wait till I'm done you
little petulant child like that is how
you treated him and it really was every
moment of these are just like [ __ ]
fatality fatality fatality finish him
you know it is those moments that are
who who would pay a lot of money to
watch Tim Ryan debate Donald Trump holy
[ __ ] dude I bet I bet we could get rid
of the national debt I bet we get rid of
the national debt ticket sales watching
Tim Ryan
ever that would be the only time Donald
Trump could ever get a big [ __ ] crowd
which by the way he was bragging about
at the at the rallies this weekend on I
think it was in Nevada in Nevada he's a
little classic crowd he was breaking him
out no no he was bragging at the biggest
crowd that he's ever had was on January
6th double down on that one it's all the
same [ __ ] and the thing that reminds
me so much about
um JD Vance creating a fake uh
non-profit or fake organization to help
people in the opioid crisis it's the
same way that I look at Donald Trump who
said and I'm almost positive this is
what he said by in a quote uh here's
this election defense fund right this
the save America pack is what he had or
is what money would go to
I will use this money he fundraised off
of the Georgia runoff election he said
send me money send me money send me
money I will back this runoff election
to make sure that the Republicans
actually win
Donald Trump did not spend one [ __ ]
penny
on that runoff he actually he actually
torched that runoff because he showed up
right and he kept telling people oh the
machines are rigged they're rigged
against you and people like I mean even
We're Not Gonna even Lynn wood was like
don't show up don't vote and I'm like
all right fine listen to the guy yeah
sure let's do that hand it hand it to
the demo right it's the same it's the
same type of [ __ ] so when you said
earlier like oh you know JD Vance and
Trump are both within the same party of
fraud oh 100 oh yeah start an
organization raise money don't spend the
money on the thing that you clean I'm
going to yeah instead of what you say
exactly pay your pay your own bills do
something else right well I mean you
know they got a lot of legal bills they
got a lot of lawyers a lot of attorneys
they're going to need them speaking of
attorneys did you hear
that one of Donald Trump's attorneys
went to Washington and had to testify in
front of federal Authority did you hear
about Bob did you hear about Bob ski oh
Christina Bob for apples Christina
Bob for apples I just feel like every
time he's doing fire today we just feel
like every time she shows up she's just
dunking herself like she's dunking on
herself by saying something and then
immediately having the opposite being
the truth or like what's going on right
she was like I didn't sign those papers
I was never really part of the Trump
defense team that was doing after these
classified documents and it's like oh
look guys I need to go back to my old
rsbn newscaster newscaster days and I'm
gonna only show up to get interviews for
the pre-show at these [ __ ] Nazi
rallies for Trump
and then you find out yeah she wasn't
she's [ __ ] dealing with this back
because she was the one who signed these
documents she was always like yeah these
uh we gave you everything you have
everything don't worry about it so let's
so let's go back let's wind back a
minute because another attorney wrote
that memo
and they wrote it and knew it was full
of lies and wouldn't sign it right they
wouldn't sign it to author to to
authenticate that memo that all the
documents that Donald Trump had stolen
from the United States government that
stole from us
that had been returned is basically what
the letter said it was certifying
through his attorney that all the [ __ ]
that you guys wanted you got which they
still don't have all the [ __ ] we know
that from Nara now they're still missing
[ __ ] they still know [ __ ] was stolen and
he hasn't returned it yeah now
Christina Bob was coerced I believe in
deciding this [ __ ] thing and that's
why her dumb ass is in huge [ __ ]
trouble here listen to me when I tell
you this
Christina Bob
is going to get sentenced to either
probation or prison listen to me when I
tell you this she's going to get
indicted she's going to be charged and
she will go before magistrate to be
sentenced it is a thing that is going to
happen she knows it her attorneys know
it
she's [ __ ] that's why she's in
Washington cooperating
now Mueller she wrote has a tweet here
and says if I say quote Christina Baba's
cooperating with with the feds I'd like
you to note that the word hero
does not appear in that sentence please
stop it easy people of calling others
Heroes for simply reporting the news why
do people find it necessary to assign
feelings to facts yeah [ __ ] your [ __ ]
your [ __ ] feelings because these
facts are not going to go away
fake game these facts are not going to
go away they're going to haunt the
[ __ ] Cheeto dust mobster for a long
time and my belief is my belief is is
that Christina Bob going and testifying
against Donald Trump in this way while
while she is on rsbn
shipping for him at rallies this is
[ __ ] weird as [ __ ] Gabe this is the
weirdest [ __ ] [ __ ] I've ever seen in
my life she literally has to go to
Washington DC to save her [ __ ] life
to save her life from being locked away
in a prison for a long time
because not only is she going to lose
her law license not only is she going to
lose her reputation she is CR she is
criminally liable here for what the [ __ ]
she did
and she knows it she knows it she's not
a dumb [ __ ] person this is the same
[ __ ]
that helped write the memo of the Cheeto
dust kangaroo coo the John Eastman memo
right to try to overturn out I mean
[ __ ] collection She's Not Innocent
she's not she's black no here's the
thing Christina people get [ __ ] as far
as I'm concerned oh 100 and I know I
know Kalyn also agrees in the chat I
mean
has been agreeing with this for a long
time she's had a long time yeah yeah but
here's the thing Christina Bob for
apples she's not a new person right
she's not a new person of interest she
didn't just show up and be like I signed
these documents and then that was it
she's been here from the [ __ ] gecko
man she's there when you know she's
there in the war room right she was
there with Eastman that whole [ __ ]
cool crew okay everyone was there she
was [ __ ] passing out drinks figuring
out how we can [ __ ] throw this coup
and get it over with right and it's just
she is not innocent she's she cannot
play this oh well I was just I just
signed the document and they forced me
to do I don't [ __ ] care you [ __ ] dumb
as [ __ ] if you sign that document
because here's the thing you're a lawyer
who put your name down and said yeah I
testify to saying that this is all true
I I I 100 tell you the truth right now
with my signature and this date
that everything that we have given you
is it I swear that's it and then she's
of course it's like why would why would
the FBI want to put you in the same
[ __ ] room when you were part of the
when you were part of this cool crew
right planning this [ __ ] you're over
here well they didn't let me in and yeah
and I don't think that's right dude
you're [ __ ] guilty as [ __ ] well the
other thing we know now but the other
thing we know now is that the son of a
[ __ ] had five pallets full of documents
and part of those documents were in this
effort to cover up and obstruct any kind
of investigation that would happen
around January 6 in their attempt to
overthrow the coup here is if you don't
know who Christina Bob is I think this
is one of the better Clips where she's
sitting in front of a green screen I
don't know it makes it look like she
look at those look at those palm trees
yeah right I don't know I don't know but
this is on Trader TV News Network real
America's voice is she on real America's
Voice or does she simp on RSB and I
can't remember
rsbn is where she's got the mic asking
everyone dumb questions I got you this
is she's she just does a media tour oh
I'm right wing fascist TV gotcha Trader
TV Christina bobsky origin car bobs for
apples let's watch this little clip here
it's
it's in New York president Trump and his
family
I did because they had the CCTV that
they were able to watch I you know I was
stuck in the parking lot there to you
know collect paper and answer questions
uh but they were actually able to see
the whole thing so they they actually
have a better idea of what took place
inside
listen when you when you do criminal
[ __ ] the last thing you really should do
like John Gotti didn't go on [ __ ] on
a TV News Network like well you know I
may know where bodies are at but that's
because that's because I kind of am
involved but I really wasn't there right
I was outside in the parking lot barking
orders and other people were doing the
killing that's what I was I was I was at
a distance so I can't tell you who the
people were but I mean they were there
yeah the last time I saw him was air
there before they broke his legs look
here's the thing
she is incred I don't know I have not
ever looked up where she got her degree
maybe it was Trump University not sure
but it would totally track
Christina Bob for apples is I'm going to
keep saying the name because I just
can't get out of my head now but she is
someone who
wants to claim that she's not that she's
not at all guilty right she's like well
they didn't let me in the room so I
don't know what they did they might have
just thrown some evidence somewhere
which by the way Trump is now claiming
all that [ __ ] is mine mine mine mine
mine but they planned it all but they
planted it so they planted what was mine
so they so my stuff was with the
government and then the government took
my stuff that I didn't actually have on
me and then put it in my office and they
planted it it doesn't make any sense
they are tripping over their own lives
well here's here's here's a clip from a
while back of Christina Bob doing just
exactly what you're saying trying to
figure out on live television they're
work shopping with Laura Ingraham what
their story is going to be this is why
she has ended up in the position where
she's had to go and be interviewed by
the feds let's watch something okay so
Christina just so I'm clear about this I
want to be really clear
is it your understanding that there were
not documents related to our nuclear
capabilities or nuclear issues that had
National Security implications in the
president's possession when the agents
showed up at Mar-A-Lago okay any real
attorney any real attorney who has had
has [ __ ] worked in the law at all
even me who has never been an attorney
who has never wanted to be an attorney
knows this question right here is a
question that you say I'm gonna have to
ask my attorney to answer that question
that's a question that I can't answer at
this point right and and the reason why
is because when she answers this
question live on television
the authorities are watching they're
watching the answer to this question
because they want to know what she's
gonna say on live television and the
answer should always be to this question
no matter who you are especially if you
have seen or not seen or suspect that
these kind of documents live in a place
that they do not belong and it may be
criminal where they're at you do not
[ __ ] even appear yeah to answer this
question don't refer to an attorney even
if you are one it really is [ __ ]
weird but watch what watch how she
responds it's [ __ ] crazy
that's correct I I don't believe they
were and if they thought well do you
know for a fact
do you know for a fact they wondered
have you spoken to the president about
it
I I have not specifically spoken to the
president about what nuclear uh
materials may or may not have been in
there I do not believe there were any in
there the legal team had done a very
thorough search and had turned over we'd
been very Cooperative with uh yeah dude
shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up look
Christina Bob to know how dumb she is is
obviously we've shown these these videos
I mean here's a photo of her inside the
uh the the Willard Hotel room right this
is the War Room meeting that's happening
you have not only that but you've got
there's another photo with other people
as well but what people need to think
about here is if you're gonna hang out
with the coup crew right now and you're
gonna try and overthrow the government
don't document it do not take photos
videos or anything else on an electronic
device that someone could then come back
and say hey so we know you were here and
you were part of this group and you also
participated XYZ
in the same way that I would say when
Christina Bob goes on to a TV show and
says [ __ ] do not talk that's like number
one thing any lawyer will tell you hey
to get pulled over by the cops don't say
anything don't shut this [ __ ] up here
are your rights yeah and there's a video
where it's like two lawyers and they're
like hey so here are things you remember
shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up shut
the [ __ ] up don't talk right but you
would think that somebody who is a well
lawyer would would know those things not
to talk do not incriminate yourself do
not impressive lawyer is she though I
mean I don't I don't I mean like I I you
know I'm gonna look it up right now I
never looked at it before because I was
like I I wanna I mean she is she
graduated she has a law degree she
actually she was she was an official at
DHS she was in the Trump Administration
she actually left the Trump
Administration to go sent for him on oan
which the original Trader TV News
Network and she was actually involved in
the [ __ ] fraud it out out in Arizona
raising money as she was an oan host on
trying to [ __ ] figure out if there
were bamboo balance and watermarks all
kinds of weird ass [ __ ]
um out in in Arizona
um but you know frankly the the longer
the short of it is is that Christina Bob
is part of Team Coupe yeah she is a
[ __ ] founding member
and that and that is what their goal is
is to overturn our democracy that's the
whole point of the whole goddamn [ __ ] in
caboodle here now I have some more clips
and I I'd love to stay on Christina but
yeah well
um I would love to talk more about
Christina Bob but we really have to move
on to um some more stuff that's going on
um this in particular there's
groundbreaking news from the president
of the United States and his son's
laptop okay this was played on Sean
Hannity's show let me tell you something
holy moly this is groundbreaking stuff
that the the current sitting president
United States James Wood in a mask
um Barack Obama's puppet or I don't know
whatever was yesterday the the video do
you remember this video I don't know
what you yeah yeah and I don't know she
said it was Barack Obama to mask or
someone else I feel like I'm gonna need
to uh I I feel like at some point I'm
gonna need to hire an interpreter like
I've tried captions with these people it
doesn't help I tried you know trying to
read Mouse to be like maybe they're
saying something they're not really
saying no I feel like they're somebody
out there needs to be an interpreter for
Maga well it's a q Anon World we're just
living in it folks but listen to this
listen to this uh crazy audio it's
groundbreaking breaking news Joe Biden
loves Hunter Biden he loves him let's
listen
I love you I love you more than the
whole world pal
you're gonna get some help I don't know
what to do I know you don't either
I'm here no matter what you need
no matter what you need I love you
so Hunter Biden is a drug addict he's
got a lot of problems and apparently
he's got some tax problems and they may
even be criminal yeah um and and Joe
Biden is worried about his his only son
that he has left yeah and they think
they think it's a winning argument to
show that Joe Biden has decency empathy
and that he actually loves his son even
though he is a drug addict even though
he's got a lot of problems
he's got a lot of personal problems even
though he may have some criminal
liability from some tax fraud that he
may have done
Joe Biden still loves his son and he
still wants his son to get help yeah
they think that's a winning they think
somehow
I can't I don't understand this is like
the best ad this is like the best ad
that you could run like really this this
is the groundbreaking [ __ ] that you've
got on Hunter Biden's laptop this is it
this is it this is what you've gathered
up is Joe Biden calling his only son
that he has left
after his entire family was killed in a
car accident years ago before he became
a senator he only had two sons left at
that point and daughter and then then he
loses his other son to cancer because
more than likely his son
committed his life to serving his
country in the military probably got
cancer from the actual fumes that are in
some of these toxic burn pits which by
the way Republicans want to stand on
this platform we want to care for our
veterans and our soldiers but then when
it comes to the actual Tar Pits nope and
funding veterans or their health care
they go nope nope especially to abolish
the VA right especially especially
Lauren bobert who decided to have that
one You Lie moment right which was under
Obama Lauren bober decided her one her
moment was going to be calling out Joe
Biden for not caring for those soldiers
who died even though his son was a
[ __ ] Soldier and here he is his only
son that he has left
pleading for him to get help telling him
that he loves him that he does not want
to see
it's crazy to have empathy toward your
family member to your only to love your
son it is well it is on brand for these
moglodytes it is on brand for these
fascists the this America First Nazi
party to not love your children they're
obsessed they're obsessed with other
people's children's [ __ ] what
bathroom they're going into and what
they what they got in the britches and
what they don't and how they identify
what their hair color is what books
they're reading but they forget that
they have their own children that
they're supposed to love right most
human beings understand this that you
know you love your [ __ ] children no
matter what though Jeffrey Dahmer's mom
still loved him
has more empathy and decency than Maga
Republicans
are you listening to my voice she still
loved her son even after the [ __ ]
monster that he was yes yes Joe Biden
loves Hunter Biden yes he does he does
not want to see his son be an addict he
doesn't probably want to see his son go
to prison if he committed crimes he
probably doesn't want that most parents
don't yeah you [ __ ] crazy crazy
concept most parents don't I I'm gonna
go on a limb here and I'm gonna say that
uh
Don Jr has never received a call like
this before in his life I would also say
that Trump we know from stories about
how he you know he came into his son's
dorm room slapped him around embarrassed
in front of his friends like that the
Trump family is a broken family that is
a broken home and again you know I
talked about in Herschel Walker what was
that that I did which is like I
empathize with anyone who comes from a
broken home but to use that as an excuse
to be an [ __ ] to use as an excuse for
every other thing that you've got going
on you know in this case scenario right
now which is like Sean Hannity plays the
clip thinking oh man I [ __ ] owned Joe
Biden and I [ __ ] got the nail on the
cob this is a Smoking Gun it's like no
this is just a guy who cares about his
son and from 2018 he saw his son was in
trouble and had issues and was it had an
addiction and still had I mean he's
still an addict right and called him up
and left a voicemail saying I care about
you I don't know I don't know how to fix
this and neither do you but we need to
get you help right and it's like how is
any of that controversial how is any of
that controversial where someone would
say oh look this is my biological son
and he has issues and I care for him you
know what Gabe maybe maybe Sean Hannity
is just giving a cry for Donald Trump to
give a [ __ ] about Donald Trump Jr for
half a second a half a second well I
wanna I wanna end on this note because
our title today is good riddance Tulsi
because we have a lot of no [ __ ]
Sherlock moments today right with like
Joe Biden uh empathy for his son that's
a no [ __ ] Sherlock moment
um Tim Ryan just pointing out facts
about Vance in front of him that's a no
[ __ ] Sherlock moment but here Kenny do
it all too real has this video about
Tulsi and I think this is an older video
and he reposed it this morning because
Tulsi decided to announce that she is
not a Democrat yeah no [ __ ] Sherlock
here's Kenny's version of no [ __ ]
Sherlock we'll see Gambit could you just
um go away girl you talk too much oh God
you never shut up God damn girl you just
oh you're always talking through the
[ __ ] nobody [ __ ] with you Aloha goodbye
[ __ ] you a fake ass Moana you're not
Ohana that's why they got video asking
why you [ __ ] nobody [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] ass you just homophobic
you're racist you're full of [ __ ] you
trying to be to the proximity of
whiteness you're a person of color but
you weaponize your purpose in the color
to constantly go after people you're
full of [ __ ] you never speak facts
you're full of [ __ ] get out of here you
look like [ __ ] Cruella Deville
but that damn streaking your goddammit
you look like a [ __ ] villain you look
like you're about to make a fur coat
made out of [ __ ] Dalmatians
shut up
shut up
shut up oh Kenny brings the heat the
heat is on this morning at the Tony
Michaels podcast it is on today we fired
it up we lit the fire and we don't stop
thank you Kenny for your video I love
his [ __ ] energy just [ __ ] yeah all
right he's the [ __ ] up dude his stuff
his recent stuff on Herschel Walker
Christian Walker is it's great it's
great you actually you actually were in
one of his uh spaces that he did yeah
last night which Christian Walker
started to um where he started to lose
his mind on social media everyone was
like what the hell is going on last
Monday which feels way longer than that
right right it feels like a year ago but
yeah I was in there and you know I
chimed in a couple times but yeah he ran
it he ran a great Twitter space and you
know everyone was out there you know
people in Georgia people from all over
the place that were talking about kind
of their perspective on the situation
that was happening but yeah I mean Kenny
In This Moment In All moments just
[ __ ] lays it out on the truth and
also just like the clap back comedic
like just the Cruella De Ville like just
this it's it's all just does seem like
she would butcher a bunch of puppy down
oh yeah totally yeah yeah 100 I mean you
could catch her red-handed doing it
you're like I didn't do it I'm not doing
it you know she's like sewing the
[ __ ] shoulders together do you think
now that she's officially officially
left the Democratic party that she gains
a Russian accent you think she her
accent starts to move towards I think
Russia I think so I mean when she when
she announced it today it almost sounded
like LeBron James being like I've
decided to take my talent to South Beach
it's like uh they're much consideration
and thought I decided to take my talents
to Russia
Russia
Russia oh my God it's not surprising you
know what else isn't surprising Gabe
that everyone loves this shirt this is
like the go it's just like hot hot just
like Today's Show the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people is not
Liberty you guys love this shirt I
actually you know what I think I'm gonna
do because we've got a coffee mug and a
t-shirt but I think I'm gonna put it on
a hoodie should we put it on a hoodie or
should we put it on a sweater which do
you think people would like better it is
starting to get cold outside yeah it's
getting cold you might might want to be
thinking about hey you know the holidays
coming up what do I want what do I want
someone to open up the first thing they
see right oh [ __ ]
the freedom to oppress the right to some
other people let me ask you if we did it
on a sweater should we do it on the
front of the back we did it on the
school I'm just saying we haven't really
put anything on the back yeah in our
store maybe we should put it on a
sweater people say I'm seeing hoodie
hoodie hoodie hoodie hoodie hoodie well
let's put it on the back of a hoodie
then okay let's do that let's put the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty the Liberty quote
on the back of a hoodie so go to store
dot meet Tony michaels.com at bookmark
it because as soon as I get off the air
here I'm going to do edits and I'm gonna
put that hoodie up for you guys to go
check it out I'll post it on Twitter
I'll post it on Twitter so don't forget
to follow us over there at Tony Michaels
pot follow me at the Tony Michaels and
follow Gabe at I am Gabe Sanchez we'll
put it over there for you guys to see
the link so you can go get the Liberty
hoodie we'll print it on the back I
might put it small in the front too like
we have to figure out what goes on there
right so we'll put something yeah we'll
we'll do something to where we got the
the big one on the back on the hoodie
maybe something on the front
um you know
business in the front party in the back
kind of thing yeah especially because
then when you're walking everyone
everyone sees you know you're not
passing by somebody in the front you
know like oh wait what was that you know
no it's really a behind the back moment
and you're you know not stalking someone
but you're just following them to read
what's on the back of the hoodie
hey everyone follow And subscribe to the
YouTube channel you're not going to want
to miss an episode and make sure to go
download every single episode today's is
fire you're going to want to listen to
it twice
um so go download Apple's modified
Google and also if you're on Facebook
right now go over to our page the at the
Tony Michaels if you're on Facebook go
follow us over there
you're not going to want to miss a thing
over there I post a lot of memes over
there on Facebook and Instagram and I
don't know if people been noticing I
post memes on YouTube some people think
I make some I make some of them but a
lot of them I just see them like in
Threads and I'm like oh God this is a
good one yeah they're gonna love this
one and I just throw it up and post it
sometimes no comment you don't really
need one with a good name you really
don't need any good comments yeah no I
just look the photo you know they say a
photo's worth a thousand words right
right so so please follow us again on
YouTube and don't forget to subscribe it
helps us out a lot and thank you for all
your support and everything that you
guys do showing up here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours
until tomorrow same time same place
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon